والصين تظهر قواتها وتقول
للامريكان لا جديد. فبكين لا
موسكو في حلب. رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي يهنئ كل من شارك في
وبوتين يبدي موافقته للسماح
لغذاء العالم بالمرور من البحر.
مسيرة الاعلام ويؤكد ان القدس
عاصمة لاسرائيل ولن يتم تقسيمها.
وتحليق مكثف لطائرات ومروحيات مع
امدادات بارتال عسكرية دفعت بها
روسية وسورية في الشمال السوري
بعد تعهد تركيا بالتدخل العسكري
تمتلكها طهران لا يمكن استبعاد
احتمال تصنيع رأس متفجر بحسب
الاوكراني ان اصعب موقف هو في
شرق اوكرانيا الوضع صعب للغاية
ابناء زايد لماذا يدعمون المحتل
ويتركون شقيقهم المظلوم؟ وعشان
روسيا تغيرت بسبب حربها ضد
اوكرانيا. الوكالة الدولية
الحلف في حل من التزاماته
السابقة نشر قوات في اوروبا
التركية. اعتبر نائب الامين
العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي ان
تصاعد اعمال العنف الاسرائيلية
على الفلسطينيين. فما الذي ينقص
الروسية للدفاع الجوي. وذلك
بعدما احجمت الولايات المتحدة عن
تسليمها لانقرة بذريعة تزويد
انقرة بمنظومة اس اربعمائة
لحرب يتوقعها الالمان قريبا?
استجابة غربية. وزير خارجية
عشرة مليارات دولار في غضون خمس
سنوات. وتم توقيع الاتفاقية وسط
خوفا من روسيا؟ تجديد التطبيع.
وقعت اسرائيل والامارات في دبي
من الرسوم الجمركية على جميع
السلع فورا او تدريجيا. كما
خمسمائة وزارة الدفاع الروسية
تعثر على شاحنة اوكرانية وهنا
الفلسطينيون والعرب عام. امريكا
تتجنب مواجهة مباشرة مع روسيا
هاي هذا في احلامك فقط فانت لست
الا محتلا فقط. يقولها
المعايير التي حددتها الوكالة
للطاقة الذرية. تعزيزات عسكرية
عام تسعين الى مائتي الف اليوم.
فهل تحضر المانيا نفسها حاليا
المستشار الالماني قد تعهد اثر
بداية الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
برصد ميزانية خاصة بمائة مليار
يورو لاعادة تسليح الجيش وتحديث
اتفاق تجارة حرة يعتبر الاول من
نوعه بين تل ابيب ودولة عربية.
خاطر مصطفى الشربيني اليكم
الاحداث والتطورات. قال الرئيس
وحسب وزارة الخارجية الاسرائيلية
سيتم استثناء ستة وتسعين بالمائة
النووي. وعلق مصدر دبلوماسي
قائلا انه مع هذه الكمية التي
للطاقة الذرية تتهم ايران بخرق
القيود المفروضة في الاتفاق
الشرقية وقال المسؤول الثاني في
الناتو ان الاوضاع والاتفاقات مع
لتزويد تركيا بمقاتلات اف ستة
عشر. لكن ملف مقاتلات اف ستة عشر
مياه النيل. مصر حذرت عديد
المرات من خطوات السد لكن دون
والسودان. وباتفاق او بدونه
سيمضون بهذه الخطوة خلال الخريف
تزويد تركيا بمنظومات باتريوت.
فهل خضع الغرب لشروط الاتراك
عن دعم التنظيمات الارهابية
ليخرج الكونجرس ويعلن توجهه
بمحاولة لربما تكون يائسة خصوصا
انها تعلم ان الصين وروسيا
نووية. ياتي ذلك بعد ان استخدمت
الصين وروسيا حقا نقض فيتو بخصوص
والغام. مبادرة في ليتوانيا
لتزويد اوكرانيا بمسيرة برقدار
لمقاتلي اوكرانيا في ازوفستال
وكان تحت الجثث اربع عبوات ناسفة
تركيا. سلمنا فرنسا والمانيا
تحضيرا خطيا شديد اللهجة بالتوقف
المحافظة على انشاء صندوق خاص
للمشتريات العسكرية قيمته مائة
معدات وكانت برلين قد قلصت عديد
جيشها من خمسمائة الف جندي في
فسننقض قرار تحضير الماني. اتفقت
الحكومة الالمانية والمعارضة
كانت المفاجأة وكان هناك في
الشاحنة مائة واثنتان وخمسون جثة
حيث نخسر من ستين الى مئة جندي
يوميا يقتلون في المعارك ونحو
الكهرباء. الاثيوبيون يعلمون ان
هناك تحديات ستواجههم من مصر
حرب المياه. تستمر اثيوبيا في
تجاهل جيرانها اذ تستعد لعملية
الصاروخية التابعة لها وضعت في
حالة تأهب لمراقبة الانشطة
ثلاثين طائرة دخلت المنطقة اكثر
من عشرين من مقاتلة. وكأن اصحاب
الدفاع الجوي التابعة للتايوان
هذا العام. اذ اعلنت تايبي ان
تقولان وان عدتم عدنا ان حاولتم
فرض عقوبات على بلد كيم جونج
الصينية الاخيرة، فهل يكفي تأهب
التيوانيين لصد التنين الصيني؟
يتوقع ان يزيد الاتفاق حجم
التجارة بين البلدين لاكثر من
له صلة بمقاتلات اف خمسة
وثلاثين. التي رفضت واشنطن
العيون الضيقة يقولون لبايدن
ارنا ما الذي تستطيع فعله؟ وذكرت
الروسيين من اماكن اخرى سيجدون
صعوبة بالغة في ذلك. ترد موسكو.
خفض وارداتها من النفط الروسي
بنسبة تسعين بالمائة بحلول نهاية
بالدول غير الصديقة في حال رفضها
الدفع بالروبل. ياتي ذلك في حين
مليار يورو لتحديث جيش البلاد
امام تهديد روسي محتمل. وكان
لدى الامم المتحدة سندعو لفرض
عقوبات ان اجرت بيونج يانج تجربة
مشروع قرار يفرض عقوبات جديدة
على كوريا الشمالية تقوم واشنطن
عقوبات ان اجرت كوريا الشمالية
تجربة نووية. السفيرة الامريكية
عسكرية لضرب السد؟ محاولة عابرة.
تهديد امريكي بتشديد طلب فرض
تهدد مياههم? وماذا عن السودان
الذي جفافا شديدا ونقصا في منسوب
جدوى. فهل ترد القاهرة بتنفيذ ما
حذرت منه مرارا وتطلق عمليات
الصين تتحدى. بينما كان بايدن قد
اعلن ان امريكا ستتدخل عسكريا
العام الجاري. فهل يقدر
الاوروبيون تعويض النفط والغاز
اتفقت دول الاتحاد السبع
والعشرون خلال قمة في بروكسل على
المقبل. لكن هل يسكت المصريون
على هذه الخطوة الخطيرة التي
والسودان لكنهم ماضون في خطوة
الملأ بغض النظر عما ستبديه مصر
اورستيد الدنماركية لعدم
المدفوعات من هاتين الشركتين
بحلول الموعد النهائي للدفع
المنصوص عليه في العقود بينهم
الملئ التالي لسد النهضة مع امل
ان ينتج سد خمسة الاف ميجاوات من
وزارة الدفاع التايوانية ان
طائراتها وانظمة الدفاع الجوي
ستوقف امدادات الغاز الى شركتي
شل انرجي اوروبا في المانيا والى
للدفاع عن تايوان نفذت الصين
ثاني اكبر توغل لها في منطقة
الامريكية. يتزامن الموقف
الامريكي ذلك مع اعلان الكريمين
وردا على العقوبات الغربية اعلنت
شركة غاز برومي الروسية انها
بالتنسيق مع انقرة. موسكو تنفذ
وعودها. بعد بلغاريا وبولندا
بالروبل. وكان بوتين قد هدد بقطع
امدادات الغاز الطبيعي عما وصفها
ان الرئيس بوتين ابلغ نظيره
التركي رجب طيب اردوجان بان
تهديدات روسيا? لكن مع ذلك فقد
رحبت موسكو بهذه الخطوة
فنحن لا نشجع اوكرانيا ولا
نمكنها لتوجيه ضربات عسكرية
بالطائرات فهل خضع الناتو لطلبات
اردوجان؟ تراجع امريكي. قال
شديد اللهجة للناتو بينما توافق
امريكا على تزويد انقرة
بلاده مستعدة لتسهيل مرور شحنات
الحبوب من الموانئ الاوكرانية
لا يهدد روسيا. ما كل هذا
التراجع هل تراجع الامريكان بعد
لحرب قادمة؟ الامارات تقترب اكثر
من اسرائيل وتركيا توجه تحذيرا
تتجاوز حدودها. بينما قال
البنتاجون تزويد اوكرانيا بنظام
زيلنسكي يصرخ نحن نخسر في اليوم
مائة قتيل ومائة مليار يورو فقط
برلين لتحديث جيشها فما الذي
يجري في المانيا؟ هل هو استعداد
والسودان فهل تجر نفسها الى حرب
كارثية؟ وبعد فشلها في فرض
الذين وعدوكم بالحماية؟ لماذا لا
يردون علينا؟ اثيوبيا تستفز مصر
عقوبات على بلاد المجنون؟ امريكا
تهدد كوريا الشمالية مجددا.
الاوروبيون يا ترى تحلق مجددا
بطائراتها فوق تايوان وتقول اين
الرئيس الامريكي بايدن. نحن لن
نزود اوكرانيا بصواريخ المدى
قرارا صائبا. بوتين يبدي
استعداده لترك سفن الحبوب تمر
نحن نعتذر. هكذا قالها بايدن
ليرد الروس بان الامريكان اتخذوا
الى العالم بالتعاون مع تركيا
ودول الغرب تفرض العقوبات على
روسيا لترد موسكو بقطع النفط عن
المانيا والدنمارك. فكيف سيرد
تخاف احدا كالعادة.
لن نستطيع تزويد اوكرانيا
بصواريخ طويلة المدى تصل لروسيا.